يعاني أحد المستشفيات الرائدة في بيروت من
أزمة ، فكم من هؤلاء
يغادرون ،
يمكنني أن أقول لك على الأقل أن
ما
لا يقل عن 25 من هؤلاء الأطباء قد
ذهبوا إلى لبنان يفقدون أحد
أغلى موارده وهم
الأطباء والممرضات.  أشعر بخيبة أمل كبيرة ،
أعني أن خيبة الأمل هذه كبيرة ، لقد
خاب أملنا في بلدنا
وسياستنا الدكتور راميريز هذه هي اللحظة التي تغير فيها كل شيء
في 4 أغسطس 2020
انفجار قوي في ميناء بيروت
هز هذا المبنى
والعديد من الفرق الطبية في العاصمة
سارع إلى علاج الجرحى السائرين
عند
بواباتهم ، حطم الانفجار ما بقي من أمل
ضئيل في لبنان
، تخلى الدكتور رود
وحجز تذكرة
ذهاب فقط إلى كندا ، لم يتبق لنا شيء هنا في
هذا
البلد بعد كل ما حدث
بين الأزمة الاقتصادية.
الانفجار الرابع من أغسطس ، القضايا الأمنية ،
كل شيء من حولنا هو فوضى كبير المسؤولين
الطبيين الدكتور جورج رانوم يقول
20 في المائة من الأطباء استقالوا
من خلال استخدام الجهاز المتطور لوحدة السكتات الدماغية
للوقوف في وضع الخمول الآن للأسف ،
فإن فريق الأطباء الذين
يقومون بذلك
يغادرون البلاد وهذا يعني أن
المزيد من الناس سيموتون من سكتة دماغية في
لبنان
وسيموت الناس وستواجه مشكلة كبيرة في
الجودة.  الرعاية هنا يمكن أن
تنقلب بعقد من الزمان ، كما يقول
قبل الأزمة ، أخبرتنا الممرضات أنهم
يكسبون حوالي خمسة وسبعين دولارًا في اليوم
الآن بسبب التضخم الذي يساوي
خمسة
دولارات فقط ، لكن رئيس الممرضات
لجنود أنا أنتمي إلى هذا البلد
وعلينا أن
تحفيز جميع الناس على البقاء هل تشعر
أن لديك التزامًا ،
فهذا ليس التزامًا ، إنه
اقتناع مدان أنه يتعين علي البقاء
ربما في الوقت الحالي لاحقًا ،
ولا نعرف أبدًا أنها تقول إن
نصف فريقها تقريبًا استقال 80 ممرضًا
في العام الماضي  سيء
لأنك تفقد أصولنا ، فنحن نفقد
ممرضاتنا الأكفاء ، فهم ليسوا
أصدقاء ، فهم ليسوا
زملاء ، بل هم عائلة ، نحن عائلة
هنا ، نحن نعمل هنا للعديد من الأشخاص
آذان وأعتقد
أن لديهم مستقبل أفضل خارج نسمح
لأطفالنا بالذهاب
لبعض CNN